oh come on
down
it's just it's not fair you're too good
yeah
it's almost like you're a professional
do it
what did you call me you knew you're
gonna call me you do you even know how
to spell it i didn't think so
take your kitchen and make me a sandwich
you probably still live at home with
your mom i'm four brother
four
guys i never realized how difficult it
would be to get a four-year-old to
listen to you
so this is i'm gonna be you someone get
up in the camera go gg no re
i'm super excited because i haven't done
a giveaway in quite some time so i'm
giving away an xbox but this one's mine
so you'll get a new one now it's super
easy to win so all you have to do is go
to bingadon.com and take their bing it
on challenge
they have two search engines stripped
down so you can't tell which is which so
all you have to do is search up to five
things choose either the left search
results or the right search results
whichever one you like better there is
no judging here once you're done
searching it'll take you to the end
screen for your final results how i'll
be choosing one of you guys to win you
just have to click that little tweet
button you see it you'll see it there
just click on that and tweet out your
results but most importantly listen my
add friends don't forget to type in at
ijustine somewhere in your tweet so that
i'll be able to see it and choose one of
you guys to win all right i'm gonna go
thank you guys so much for participating
i look forward to seeing all of your
bing it on challenge results and picking
the winner for the xbox and now let's
watch some outtakes of oh trying to get
a small child to listen to me
hmm
okay you're beating me now so get real
excited yay
and so act like i'm talking so you're
talking to me in the headset so i can
hear you in the headset so
get real
excited so if you want a sandwich you
tell me to get in the kitchen and make
one get back in the kitchen and make me
a sandwich
get a bigger kitchen and make me a
sandwich
that's amazing oh my gosh you're so
funny you're so good maybe if you want
to get like up close to the camera so
you get to get your face up there and be
like
say gg no re
g
no more okay um i think that's good is
there anything else you'd want to say
if i was playing this game and you were
winning